new york 2 retrouve son rythme
pas à pas libérer un peu plus
aujourd'hui du carcan sanitaire mis en
place contre la copie de 19
de nombreux établissements non plus à
restreindre leurs capacités d'accueil
pour des résidents comme celui ci à
brooklyn
c'est encourageant ça nous aidera dit il
à sortir de notre tanière et c'est une
lueur d'espoir pour ce petit théâtre où
se jouent la doyenne des pièces new
yorkaise de perrefitte prime le crime
parfait
car si la troupe a retrouvé les planches
avec bonheur j'apprécie encore plus mon
métier dans cette comédienne qui tient
ce rôle depuis 34 ans un bonheur partagé
avec des spectateurs
reste que depuis que l'endroit a eu la
permission de rouvrir le mois dernier
sous de strictes conditions sanitaires
il roule à perte toutefois elle voit mal
comment remplir ses salles à 100% c'est
pour continuer à y imposer la
distanciation sociales sacais
elle songe donc aménager des sections
pour les spectateurs vacciner pour le
grand retour de broadway
il faudra toutefois attendre septembre
une quarantaine de salles maintiennent
leur calendrier de rodage de leur
spectacle dans l'un de ses restaurants
ce français installé depuis longtemps à
new york souligne que l'un des défis du
retour à la normale c'est la main
d'oeuvre
c'est terrible on est obligé de fermer
la balle mardi
et ici le lundi parce que on n'a pas
cette staff
les cuisiniers ils n'en peuvent plus
parce que y'a plus personne
comme beaucoup de ses collègues et
l'installer des tables dehors
après une première fermeture puis la
réouverture limitée du service des
salles à manger on n'aurait pas survécu
c'est impossible
il reconnaît sans être bien sorti grâce
à la fidélité des gens du quartier
il sent que la levée des restrictions
est de bon augure on a doublé notre
capacité d'accueil
donc on va rattraper le retard c'est sûr
et puis même potentiellement
nos revenus dans un parc tout près de
chez lui à brooklyn
cet expert en santé publique trouve que
ces assouplissements sont prématurées de
10,1 souligne que la vaccination dont le
succès incite les autorités à relâcher
la pression et inégale d'un quartier à
l'autre
à new york il y a toujours de la
transmission communautaire de la coved
dit il ils s'inquiètent particulièrement
de ce qui pourrait se passer dans le
métro même si le port du masque dans les
transports publics restent obligatoires
pour l'instant ce sont plutôt des new
yorkais des touristes venus des états
unis que l'on voit dans les principales
attractions et les parcs de la ville et
des limites demeure par exemple sur les
grands événements à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur
n'empêche new york revient de loin
[Musique]